[Music]
yeah uh dishonest reporter at the
Washington Post just got a glorious
well-deserved roast thanks to the owner
of Barstool Sports Dave Portnoy catching
wind of a hit piece they were writing
about him apparently the Democracy dies
in the darkness doofuses had been
reaching out to the sponsors of a pizza
event that he hosts and asking if they
felt comfortable being associated with
him
wapo didn't bother giving Portnoy a call
before hand for comment so he called
them
you're basically sending an email that
says to the effect Dave's a misogenic
racist I haven't said anything like that
if you want I can read what you actually
sent I have it we are planning to write
about the festival and how and how some
of the sponsors and participants have
drawn criticism by seemingly to
associate themselves with Dave Portnoy
who has a history of misogenic comments
and other problematic Behavior that's
the one I said which was definitely the
most pointed of them that is pretty
pointed you said you didn't do it then I
have the exact evidence of you doing it
so I didn't say I didn't
judge it that was the one that was the
most well no you that what before I
before I provided proof you said you
didn't really remember doing that and
then I read it to you and you're like oh
yeah I did it that one time so you did
do it wow she backpedaled like Lance
Armstrong in a windstorm but by the way
David's misogynistic I didn't know what
you were talking about those smear
tactics seem pretty shocking but
apparently that is how the liberal media
operates
standard journalistic stuff like
unfortunately yes I was hoping for a
dialogue with them you know sometimes
you have to say something like this is
like you know it's sort of a reporting
tactic when you want someone to respond
you kind of have to indicate that there
might be something negative and then you
get them to engage that's all I was
trying to do I really wanted them to
engage with me that is a sad state of
Journalism if that's a tactic that you
have to what I would say is make up
something about somebody
amen we reached out for common from wapo
multiple times but we haven't heard back
if you want to hear more from point Port
Noy he will be on Jesse's show tonight
help him with the ratings uh so Jesse uh
um this was not about a story it was a
strategy to damage a business by
targeting and scaring advertisers we all
know how that feels I mean why is the
food editor trying to get a pizza
Festival canceled
this is uh corporate terrorism she's
supposed to be doing reviews for food
it's not like he made her samasubuko
that wasn't well presented this is a guy
who's not even a chef yeah he doesn't
even own a restaurant and this food
critic is trying to take down a
charitable event yes this is a pizza
party to help small business owners and
she's trying to destroy it so you have
Media Matters that run ad boycotts to
take down popular companies and people
and then you have journalists that run
ad boycotts to take down popular people
they're the same thing this is an agenda
so why do they have this agenda why is
Dave Portnoy such a threat that's the
question I'm going to ask him tonight
because for the Washington Post they
don't compete against Barstool stewards
is it because he's Politically Incorrect
it's because they're not in the same
tribe is it because hate sells or
division cells I don't know but this
woman and we get this all the time
you've gotten it you've gotten it this
is what they do they go in the editor
tells them what to write stories 95
written they call all your sponsors or
all your advertisers and everybody that
hates you and then they write about all
of your controversies and then five
minutes before the deadline they say hey
you'd like to read a comment exactly and
then you just check the box boom and
then it's going to kill you and it's the
most disgraceful and dishonest thing the
fact that she got caught and then lied
yes and says this is a journalistic
tactic now tell me if this is journalism
you lie to some sponsor and say
your house is on fire you got to call me
back and then they call you back and say
your house isn't actually on fire but it
might be if you don't do what we say
that's not journalism that's a threat
she's taking hostages and this is
disgraceful I'm so glad he recorded it I
wish I could record it
they're doing one on me right now and I
know it's going to go about the same way
oh poor Jesse jump on that grenade for
you yeah better Dana you do not seem
Smarter with glasses but it's okay so
Dana it was so refreshing it's a lesson
that you should record things when
reporters call you but what's worries
him is that most people don't have the
savviness or experience to know what to
do like what Dave did because he's in
the media he's in the media but a lot of
people who get called by a reporter they
think the reporter has their best
interest in mind yeah wow yeah although
I think in this case uh he has shown
people how you can do it and also there
are now the tools to do it so I've
worked in Republican Communications for
a long time back then you didn't there's
no way for you there's no recourse and
there was one guy a guy whose name was
oh Michael isakov yes from Newsweek at
the time when we worked at justice
department right after 9 11 I swear to
you every Friday at 502 pm he would call
and say well have I got a story that's
going to ruin your weekend no and then
you would have to scramble on Fridays at
five o'clock and it happened every
weekend I appreciate all the work that
he did on it but it would really be one
of those things where you think he's
already written the story all he wants
is a comment from us and watch when
conservatives are quoted it's almost
always the last quote in the story and
it's maybe one sentence out of 25 that
you gave them nothing that really
defends yourself and it's a real pain in
in the rear so I think that now that
there are ways that you can get this
information out on social media that
you're not powerless yeah if this
happens yeah that's that's a heartening
part Jessica on the upside the reporter
was just offered a job at CNN
do you uh is there any way to defend her
behavior do you buy her excuse
I didn't actually even get an excuse
that or I I didn't see anything I
thought well she lied and then she said
oh I'm saying I didn't see her really
defending it in any sort of coherent way
it just seemed like I don't know why she
wouldn't have hung up frankly that's
what I would I would have taken the L
after about three minutes and I would
have called she said she had someone
that she's writing this with I would
have called him her up and said
or completely aft yeah like this yeah
this is not gonna go well
um and I think that you do need to think
about in advance the subject of your
piece if you are trying to write this
piece with this angle right you're going
to ignore the pizza component and you
want to go for the misogyny and there's
plenty of Dave Portnoy misogyny on
record right this isn't something that
would surprise anyone it is part of his
image it has been around for as long as
Dave Portnoy has been around on record I
don't know what is he said I don't read
his stuff okay I mean he's calling a
misogynist you're doing what she's doing
but you need to have some kind of backup
do you have some quotes I do I wrote
them down and and I I want to say I
enjoy a lot of Dave portnoy's content he
my local pizza place blew up because he
came and did one of his reviews and I
don't have anything against barcel I
know exactly what it is but you could
look at the comments about ESPN host Sam
Ponder saying her job's Number One
requirement is to make men hard he
called her an effing s-l-u-t that's not
nice said Harvey Weinstein had been
making legitimate quote Fair Trades
obviously Harvey Weinstein was not
making any kind of fair trade
oh what she did is she martyred him
right I was reading the comments on
Twitter he posted the video and then
people are saying I really don't like
Dave Portnoy but this is horrible how
could The Washington Post do this and so
he walks out of this as king of the
castle and he got to remind people which
was an amazing thing that he did how
much money he raised for folks during
covid when the pp loans PPP loans
weren't necessarily coming through and
became a bit of a small business hero
there
um it's disappointing and I don't think
that she's correct that this is the way
that journalism works I think that she
slandered a lot of very good journalists
who would not have led with an email
saying Dave Portnoy this doesn't have to
do with pizza I just want to talk about
all the bad stuff that's a good uh a
good point judge is this a rule or an
exception to the rule do you think this
is ha like is she just one of the bad
ones or is she smearing an entire group
um reflecting an entire group yeah I
think that she's reflecting an entire
group I think that this clearly confirms
that there is a media media bias I think
it confirms the way she conducted
herself this doesn't sound like it's out
of the ordinary I mean you know first
she tried to hide and then she denied
and then she lied and then she puckered
out at the end and didn't even want it
he said hey I'm here you want to
interview me interview me and then the
question is how long does someone have
to be tarnished by allegations many of
which have never been proven in court so
I mean you know you can have an opinion
but this is about pizza she's the food
writer okay during the pandemic this guy
was a hero this guy saved people's
businesses he raised almost Health rates
almost 30 million dollars so what you
want to do is you want to take away the
sponsors from him trash him and end him
none of that makes sense as part of a
food writer's Mission this is a
political agenda and it's not something
that happens just once in a while it
happens a lot depending upon what side
of the style you're on I don't think
Portnoy is a conservative by the way I
mean he is very pro-choice and has been
very loud about that so he's a business
person he believes in Merit he believes
in capitalism he believes in a lot of
the stuff we believe in yeah but your
point is is well taken which is like
it's a food call and this is again
another example of politics invading
areas whether it's sports or
entertainment now it's food ladies stick
to making donuts hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else